you're in Adventure Bay here we call the
PAW Patrol you got to call the
who PAW Patrol PAW Patrol we be there on
the double whenever there's a problem
round Adventure Bay rer and his team of
PS will come and save the day Marshall
Rubble Chase Rocky Zuma Sky yeah they're
on the way PAW Patrol PAW Patrol
whenever you're in trouble Paw Patrol
Paw Patrol we'll be there on the double
no jobs too big no pups too small Paw
Patrol we're on a roll so here we go Paw
Patrol woh Paw Patrol woh Paw
Patrol all right pups here we go let's
work together up
there Rocky I need you to shut down the
bridge and control traffic Earth clear
[Music]
Zuma I need you to keep that Waterway
clear nobody under the bridge you've got
it Ryder Waterway
[Music]
secure Chase it's all up to you use the
winch in your PT pack to get the driver
and bring him to safety chase is on the
[Music]
case our grappling
hook sir don't be alarmed I'm coming
down oh thank you thank you thank you
the rescue team is
here a dog actually sir I'm a puppy a
baby dog that's even worse you're in
shock so I'm not going to take that
personally now let's get you out of here
no way I'm waiting right here here for
real
rescue I changed my mind I'll go with
you Ryder these cables aren't going to
hold much longer let's go chase get him
out of there we're coming
out don't panic I need you to stay
calm no deal I'm freaking out then
you're really not going to like
this we're not going to make it we're
not going to make
[Music]
it you can open your eyes
now oh we made
it great work Paw
Patrol everybody get back the truck's
leaking
gas oh come on that's not gas that's the
stuff I've been holding from coast to
coast that is pure Canadian maple syrup
okay time to clean up this mess deploy
waffles pancakes and French
toes Ryder Ryder where are
you Ryder I can see your light hang
on I can do this I can do this I I can
do this AR grappling
hook oh
[Music]
no disconnect
pack
[Music]
Ryder I chose you because you were the
bravest pup I'd ever
[Music]
seen
Ryder
Chase I can't believe you found me you
can always count on me
Ryder
come on we got to get out of here I
can't I'm
stuck on three pull as hard as you can
one 2
3 come
[Music]
on it won't
budge one more
try
[Music]
you did
it we did
it I told you you were a hero now come
on let's get out of
here okay okay give them some
[Laughter]
air how do you
feel covered in drool I can't help it
I'm a bulldog my tongue is too big for
my mouth see
[Laughter]
you did good
[Music]
[Applause]
pups time for me to get out of
here hey mayor
Humdinger you are under arrest for gross
negligence public endangerment and
dognapping
you can't arrest me I'm the
mayor he's getting
away mini
[Music]
Dron hey he hey hey
hey put me down nobody makes a fool of
Mayor Humdinger five times in the same
game
who wow this is humiliating here you go
boss that's
[Music]
better Adventure City is our home it's
up to all of us to take care of it stand
clear of the closing do
please but once in a while a group of
Heroes go above and beyond the Call of
Duty
they look out for their neighbors before
they look out for
themselves and they're so darn cute I
just want to squeeze them it is our
great honor to present the key to
Adventure City to the PAW
[Applause]
[Music]
Patrol me and the Paw Patrol we go way
back
and to think I knew them before they
were famous hey
Rubble I got something for
you I am never taking this
off I want to take this special occasion
to introduce you to the newest member of
the Paw Patrol Adventure City's very own
[Applause]
[Music]
liberty
my own pup tag welcome to the family
Liberty I'm official hey check it out
I'm officially official official member
of the Paw Patrol right here the meteor
is stronger than I
expected I don't have enough
power
that is not
good
338 there is wo
oh I didn't think it would be so bright
it looks like it's headed straight for
us that's because it is everybody out of
the pump
[Music]
Tower get those people inside go go go
everybody out of the street need to take
cover right now now take shelter the
meteor's heading straight for
[Music]
us everybody inside get
[Applause]
[Music]
inside come on buddy get up let's
go get out of the street we don't have
much
time
clear St clear clear good job pups now
take
cover get
down
is everybody
okay I'm
good I'm fine but I'm going to need a
serious
bath oh my
goodness wait where are the junior
patrollers Nano Mini
what wow that was
epic I'm so glad nobody got hurt oh no
look get back
here it's a dead end turn
around
looks like it's the end of the road Paw
Patrol what do we do I don't know we're
[Laughter]
trapped Junior Patrol is on a roll it's
the Junior
patrollers what is that get it off get
it
[Music]
off operation
allergies he's going to
[Music]
blow Marshall the crystals in his jacket
pocket I'm on
[Music]
it got it oh no you don't
Marshall Nobody messes with giant
Humdinger if you mess with the fire pup
you're going to get burned oo that's a
hot oneliner he's
shrinking w
oh
stop
stop Humdinger you're going back to jail
oh not
again that's what I'm talking about lean
mean fluffy little rescue machine H in F
you rad with
[Music]
me nice work Marshall let's take that
Crystal and go get
[Music]
Sky all right puppies play time's over
give me back that
Crystal
Zuma
[Music]
where'd it go over here
dude you got to be faster than
that you can't hide
[Music]
forever these crystals belong to us dude
dude
[Music]
no it's time to shut down that meteor
magnet once and for
all hey
Rebel want to go for a ride Teamwork
Makes the Dream Work
[Music]
no no stop what are you doing
fire oh yeah how Do You Like Me
Now Victoria Vance you are under arrest
oo you're in big trouble you'll have to
catch catch me
first where do you think you're
[Music]
going M must think you're so smart but
those meteors are coming down whether
you like it or
not she's telling the truth there's
hundreds of meteors heading straight for
the
city what have you done what can I say I
guess I am a man
[Laughter]
scientist finally she admits it